peu
oh
mireille vécue par école
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la victoire est belle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
situation idéale c'est vrai la mer était
de pas de l'autre côté de la route
temps idéal c'est vrai aussi en camargue
il fait presque toujours beau côté des
prix c'est vrai encore rien à dire
cornet de frites de francs 50 poulets
rôtis ou lapin chasseur à 5 francs c'est
raisonnable ajoutant que l'on a retrouvé
les amis de l'an passé bref on passe de
bonnes vacances
quant au reste on en parle généralement
beaucoup moins dans les cartes postales
le reste c'est cela cinq mille personnes
entassées dans un camping de 600 places
avec seulement 6 points d'eau et 70 du
ch fin juillet début août
ici avec un peu de chance on obtenait un
bout de terrain à peine 50 mètres carrés
côté route moyenne environ 15 francs par
jour
tarif 2 étoiles car nous sommes dans un
camping deux étoiles
ça fait cinq années combien et
vraiment la région nous nous convient
mais le camping pas du tout on a créé
tout le midi on n'a rien trouvé on est à
l'écouté de tout le monde n'a rien rien
rien trouvé 4 de moins cette année trop
les anciens sont les autres avaient été
voir le secteur
moi je m'accommode facilement j'ai
choisi le moment où événement 1er ont
l'arrogance un loyer mais lorsqu'il
pleut les allées sont deviennent de
véritables rivières league et en tonnage
les gens sortent comme il pleure ça fait
presque un mot combat est ici on n'a pas
regardé les gens aiment mon plat midi
j'ai eu peur de l'après midi et utilise
son pot de chambre qui fait sa vaisselle
camping vraiment digne de recevoir déjà
cinq ans aurait pu dépasser c'est pas
moi qui le dit mais c'est le ministre
jarraud qui a dit il a écrit ce journal
c'est un camp de réfugiés près à celle
ayant la peau en pleine propriété du
gard chou mètres séparent les plus
dépendants à concentration où les tout
la faute en herbe caméra vous a demandé
l'autorisation à claquer deux films et
autres membres de ce club c'est pas le
même
alors y est que quand même malgré tous
les problèmes
on revient et je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
de personnes mais d'un mondial ceux qui
n'ont pu trouver de place au camping
municipal sont allés tout simplement un
peu plus loin faire du camping sauvage
et ils étaient nombreux le 15 août
record d'affluence plus de quarante
mille personnes ont envahi cette plage
de 15 km de long en bordure du parc
naturel de camargue
ni eau ni sanitaires dans cet immense
camp de toile où 30 tonnes d'ordures
sont ramassées quotidiennement
les camarguais sont en colère pour eux
c'est un véritable bidonville de l'été
pas autre chose
les camps quand on les voit je crois que
même s'il ya une petite place je crois
qu'on la laisse à quelqu'un d'autre et
puis on peut faire du camping sauvach
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
évoque alors un peu de liberté pas être
parqués comme des bêtes ils sortent de
thann et de leur hlm de leur vision il
aimerait bien avoir un peu de liberté
et si vous lâchez des miellés personnes
dans des bus au bout de quelques années
les dunes complètement disparu parce que
la végétation est morte
lebron d'arbustes ont été coupés pour
faire des grillades et les fleurs
sauvages nous avions ce qu'on appelait
la vallée de lys qui était rempli de
listes sauvage allez voir aujourd'hui
comme il en reste tout ça ça disparu
pourquoi parce que les campeurs sauvages
sont passés par là il faut des compères
mais pas en quantité comme il ya en ce
moment et pour nous ça fait fuir la
clientèle la camargue et belle hors
saison mais l'été c'est une catastrophe
je crois qu'ici finalement qu'est-ce qui
empêche de faire un terrain de camping
là il ya trente kilomètres de plages
dites moi ce qui en reste de faire
internet en plus large chacun peuvent
payer une participation aux frais merci
à l'est refusent les pays et même pas
nous commerçants mes parents ont refusé
[Musique]
la municipalité des saintes maries de la
mer a répondu aux doléances des campeurs
sauvages avec la création d'un nouveau
camping de 20 hectares qui accueillera
l'an prochain environ 6000 personnes
et puis elle projette également
d'équiper en installations sanitaires
quelques kilomètres de plage à l'origine
de cette crise du camping la ruée vers
l'eau d'un trop grand nombre de campeurs
sur six millions d'entre eux près de 4
millions ont choisi cette année les
bords de mer de lacs ou de rivières
or il n'y avait qu'un million cinq cent
mille places pour les accueillir le
secrétariat d'état au tourisme prépare
actuellement un plan camping ayant pour
objectif de doubler le nombre des
emplacements
[Applaudissements]
une réforme importante car l'an prochain
ils seront encore plus nombreux au
rendez-vous de la mer et du soleil
reste à souhaiter que ce sera avec un
brin de confort en plus et ce genre de
spectacle en moins
[Musique]